[Music]  adèle cancels her remaining tour dates  the 29 year old singer took to social  media to post an emotional message to  fans on Friday announcing she would not  be able to finish the final two dates at  London's Wembley Stadium on July 1st and  second revealing in the note she has  damaged her vocal cords writing in part  the last two nights at Wembley have been  the biggest and best shows of my life to  say I'm heartbroken would be a complete  understatement  this comes after Adele hinted she may  never tour again while performing at  Wembley Stadium Thursday night she  distributed a handwritten letter in the  concerts programme which was later  shared to an Instagram fan account after  spending 15 months making tour stops  around the world she explained why she  is considering retirement quote touring  is a peculiar thing it doesn't suit me  particularly well I'm a real homebody  [Music]